hello everyone and welcome to the CEREC
international candidates tournament of
1953 I was a very strong and well very
famous chess tournament the winner of
this tournament will get a privilege to
challenge Mikhail Botvinnik for the
title and just to get the idea of how
strong the tournament was I'll read the
list of names like I said I'm reading
this book
Zurich international chess tournament of
1953 by David Bronstein and as I go
through the games if I if I find an
interesting or an instructive game I
will show it on my channel so here it is
the winner of the tournament was Smith
Slav and lastly Smith won the tournament
with 16 points to 2 whole points ahead
of David branched and author of this
book who got second place so we have
Smith's love
Bronstein carries Reshevsky Petrosyan
Geller
neither of court of time on of Auerbach
bozlovski is obligor each you may
install Berg so so an amazing tournament
definitely and well this is a game
between the last loss Sabo can get a
hungarian grandmaster and FM Geller
I think eller needs no introduction he
was a famous coach of Boris Spassky and
later Anatoly Karpov world renowned
Grandmaster so all in all this is a game
between two of the world's top
grandmasters and well the title of this
video is how even a grandmaster doesn't
fully understand the weaknesses of the
squares and this is what the diamond
Bronstein explains in this game and he
says that it took him a long long time
to really understand what where the dark
square weakness means he says that well
he always thought that a dark square
weakness meant that his opponent didn't
have a dark squared Bishop and that his
his pawns will be under light square so
he thought that this was a dark square
weakness but later only he found out
that a dark where dark square weakness
also means a light square weakness
because he has to use the dark squares
to attack his opponent's pieces on the
light squares and this game perfectly
illustrates one such idea and also it
sits
it's an instructive game from a
psychological point of view as at one
point Sabo was better and then another
India in the other point of the game the
game was pretty much drawn but Sabo
still wanted to win the game just
because he was at one point better but
ok let's see this game so Laszlo Sabo
has the white pieces and he plays c-4
Geller responds with Knight to f6 we
have g3e 6 and Bishop to G 2 D 5 D for
the cattle and opening D captures on c4
and Queen to a4 would check I'm going
after the c4 pawn with a queen Knight B
to d7 92 f3 a6 now preparing b5 but
Queen captures on c4 and here we have b5
& ok a normal response here will be
something like maybe Queen to d3 Queen
to c2 but Sabo gets an idea he creates a
plan how to how to create the dark
square weaknesses in his opponents camp
and well his idea is that he will
undermine these pawns the a pawn and the
b-pawn that are on light squares he
wants to exchange his dark square Bishop
and c1 for his opponent bishop on f8 and
at some point he wants to put B for the
lock these pawns on the light squares so
he plays Queen to c6 now attacking the
rook on a8 rook to b8 was played and now
Bishop to F for attacking c7 here black
defends this with Knight to d5 now
attacking the bishop on f4 and also
protecting this pawn on c7 so we have
Bishop to g5 wouldn't attack on the
Queen and if black doesn't want to
repeat any moves like Knight to f6 or
weaken his structure with f6 which would
be terrible Queen captures on e6 he has
to play Bishop to e7 and this is what
Laszlo had in mind this is how he
exchanges the Bishop Bishop captures on
e7 Queen captures and c7 and on e7 and
he castles Bishop to b7 now Queen to c2
and we have c5 d captures on c5 Knight
captures and e-file on c5 and rook
see one Rock the CH now defending the
knight on c5 and Knight the c3 and
already here branched and criticizes
Geller for playing Knight to f6 more
resilient move would be nice to be six
here but okay he played Knight to f6 and
Laszlo continued with his plan he played
before kicking away the night from from
c5 and also locking these pawns on a
light square so he can attack them later
but instead of playing before Bronstein
suggests that even better was Knight
captures on d5 and after a capture some
b5 now played before as the knight
cannot move wife will regain the night
winning upon and after if the knight
moves for example nice to before then
Queen captures unsee it with Czech
Bishop captures and rook captures and c8
the King has to go to the 7 and our rook
captures rook on h8 and with two rooks
for the Queen and the strong Bishop on
g2 White would have a very satisfying
game but probably maybe I mean not
probably maybe Geller saw this and he
thought that this wasn't good for white
and maybe even sabah saudis and decided
that it wasn't good for white as well so
he continued with his plan b for locking
the pawns and kicking the night away
Knight to a4 now pinning this night as
there's a rockin c8 Queen to b3 now
Knight captures rook captures rook
captures on c3 Queen captures on c3 and
gehler castles here we have rook a to C
1 this is all well so far as Abba did
everything pretty much great he's not
controlling the C file this these bones
are still locked on a white square and
if he can somehow get this f3 Knight for
example to c5 to attack the a6 pawn this
would be practically winning for him and
here a Geller plays rook to d8
unfortunately gellar cannot play rook to
c8 that the contest white for the C file
because if he plays rook to see it then
again Queen captures and C it is a very
unfortunate for black
Bishop captures rook captures with check
and after night eh
Knight to e5 preparing Bishop to c6 and
black cannot stop this
for example g6 Bishop to c6 Queen
capture some b4 and Bishop captures and
with a rook and two pieces for the Queen
threatening all sorts of discoveries
this f7 point is gonna fall this would
be extremely good for white selector up
to c1 Geller had to play rook to d8 I
will a3 now adding protection to the B
for porn nice the d5 Queen d4 we have f6
not allowing this night any activity
through a 5 or g5 and well now pretty
much all of samos pieces are perfectly
placed
except this night he would really like
this night to be uncie v and well so he
starts to get this plan in motion
he plays Knight to e1 gellar plays e5 as
he does have a plan how to stop his
knight from coming to c5 and this is the
critical moment of the game that
Bronstein really well really enjoys here
as Abba played Queen to c5 and Gail are
immediately exchanged Queens with Queen
captures on c5 but this is why a branch
then says that even talk grandmasters
don't really really understand a dark
square weaknesses or weaknesses it
doesn't have to be a dark square
weakness one should always consider a
move like Queen to a7 as Queen to a7
really keeps this dark diagonal under
control and it's pressuring the weak
points that are on the light squares so
if you if you consider a move like Queen
to a7 you should always ask yourself can
black do something about this Queen
being on a 7 and as branchline says it
black cannot smoke the White Queen out
for example if rook to e8 this falls
terribly the Bishop captures on d5 with
check so if you move the King Queen
character some b7 and if you capture the
bishop you lose the Queen so definitely
definitely after this Queen to a7 move
rook to e8 is out of the question rook
to d8 would be an even well a blunder
just as great if rook to d8 and then
Queen captures on b7 and black lost the
bishop you can't really recapture the
Queen because of Bishop captures and
defy would check and after King f8 you
get rook to see a to check the King has
nowhere to go
Queen Queen 2:8 simply grab the Queen
and then grab the rook on b7 white is up
to pieces this is very nice for white so
what else can black do after Queen to a7
obviously I mean Queen to a7 doesn't win
the game well he can try a move like
like King to f8 not allowing any tactics
with Bishop to d5 check but if he wastes
a move to play King to f8 then White has
time to improve Knights to d3 and now if
you play rook rook to a to kick away the
Queen now Queen to c5 is an extremely
good move because now black cannot trade
Queens if Queen captures Knight captures
and well white loses a piece black loses
a piece or the exchange the bishop on b7
is attacked also the knight on d5 is
attacked only way the defend this is
rook to c8 to pin this night because the
rook is on c1 and here simply Bishop
captures on d5 Bishop captures and
Knight to d7 would check King has to go
away
I wrote captors on C 18 captures Knight
and the rook to h8 with a completely
winning position for white being up the
exchange he's just gonna gobble up all
of those pawns
so after this Queen to a7 this is the
well seems like a perfectly good move I
mean if black can't refute it but to
even consider a move like this
you have to you don't really really be
aware of the dark square weaknesses one
other way
black could contest this move is a move
like 'if or but here white has a couple
of options
even with wood a move like this he can
even capture it and after Queen captures
Queen capture some b7 and
Queen captures any two captured upon an
a6 and it's it's an unclear position
black is a bit more active but - white
is up upon so even this even even this
could be playable for white and even if
you don't want to capture this efore
point you can play a move like f3
threaten the pawn and after f5 simply
capture capture and then get your Bishop
on this other strong diagonal also with
a with a nice position for white but it
it's unknown if Sabo even considered a
move like the Queen to a7 so after a 5
his queen is attacked he played Queen to
c5 and yeller exchanges the Queen's and
here rook captures and c5 was probably I
mean I probably wrote captures and see
if I was the only move that could give
any advantage to white whatsoever but
Sabo played be captures on c5 he thought
that this pin on the white and the black
knight and well the threat of c6 c7 and
c8 was enough to win the game but Gaylor
manages the defenders pretty easily he
plays Bishop to c6 blocking the pawn and
well that's pretty much it
rook to d1 rook to d7 now Bishop to h3
with some trick tricks if the rook moves
maybe Bishop to e6 check picking up the
night but of course rook to e7
now Knight the sea to a5 as the threat
was nice to be for Bishop to back to g2
now rook back to D 7 Bishop back to h3
rug back to e7
so obviously Geller is offering a draw
with the repetition of moves if if Sabo
just plays a bishop to g2 one more time
but this is the death psychological
moment in the game as Laszlo was better
at one point in the game but he's
nothing anymore dishes are completely
drawn and game he plays King to f1 he
doesn't want he doesn't want to draw and
this will be well the beginning of his
downfall King to f7
Gallery says okay you don't want to draw
I'll just improve the position of Mike
now the rook no longer has to defend
East six he's free to go to c7 to attack
your c5 pawn and here with a move like
Bishop the g2 he could still maybe draw
because now the position is better for
black so with Bishop the g2 he could
still hope to draw but he plays King to
e1 this isn't a good move it's just a
move that allows the game to continue
even even if it's in blacks favor so
rough the c7 the c5 pawn is now
undefendable rook to d3 now Bishop to b7
opening out the attack on the pawn nice
to e3 and now capturing the night sorry
the pawn Knight to f5
we have Bishop the c6 because there was
a threat of Knight to d6 to with check
picking up the bishop on b7 so check
dink to f8 we have Bishop - G - now g6
King D - King to e7 Knight has to go
back black is up a pawn and well he has
two points on the Queen side white has
only one this is for effing Yeller this
is just a matter of time before he wins
this game rocked the c4
we have f3 now f5 kicking the night away
even further knife to f2 not rook a4 and
now this rope is pretty much forced to
defend the pawn and a three nights to d1
we have E 4 F captures have captures now
the rook has to move rook to b3 now rook
checks king C 1 B 4 now this the plan is
clear you have to create a passed pawn
on the Queen side and simply push it to
victory nice day three nights the c3 we
have a capture some before now
threatening to capture the c3 Knight
Knight captures any - with check King
has to go b1 now Bishop to a for
attacking the rook rook b2 and now
Knights the c3 check King goes to C 1
and now a captures on before Geller has
created a past
that is unopposed and well soon soon it
will be all over a rock to d2 we have
worked capture skin captures and now
simply improving the position of his own
king is sufficient to win this game
Knight to g4 King c5h 4 in d4 h 5g
captures on h5 Knights day 3 the Knights
to be one with check King to e2 now
Bishop checks on b5 King F 2 and now b3
and being down three pawns and well
there's really no way for you to stop
this point from B b2 and b1 a lot of
sabor the Hungarian Grandmaster resigned
in this game
so this is why Bronstein thinks that
this is a very instructive game because
well if if White had considered that
Queen to a7 move this entire game would
have been completely different
white would have continued to you know
to have pressure and that's from
diagonal on this diagonal and white
pawns the black ones would be stuck on a
six and A five still they still there
would be weak points they would be able
to attack I mean he would be able to
attack the pawns and what he decided for
Queen to c5 and well instead of that
rook captures and c5 he played B
captures on c5 and his position simply
deteriorated in one move he went from a
winning position to a drawn position and
then he refused the draw because you
know one blunder follows another and
with that last King move he went into a
completely losing endgame so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it this is
only game one in the book and well if
all games are this instructive I am
really going to enjoy going through this
book I would like to thank Matthew
Butler and Dylan Thomas for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with more bronstein
instruct
tunas Susan